un spectacle 100% masculin
mélangeonglage acrobatie trapèze
performance musicale et humour la
machine de cirque débarque à la réunion
sur scène 6 artistes québécois qui
bougent avec agilité dans un décor
post-apocalyptique
[Musique]
au spectateur de créer sa propre image
pour chacun des tableaux et de créer son
propre monde en fait plutôt que de
présenter uniquement de la technique
pour faire waouh être spectaculaire on
veut vraiment qu'il y a un fond derrière
chacun des tableaux
[Musique]
et même à ébahir les spectateurs pendant
une heure et demi ces artistes proposent
ce qu'ils appellent le nouveau cirque le
cirque c'est la même technique que vous
voyez plus auparavant mais c'est sans
toutes les le superflu si je peux dire
donc maintenant c'est très c'est ce qui
est plus à la mode c'est des costumes
plus sobre moins de maquillage moins de
d'effets spéciaux donc c'est beaucoup
plus intime je pense comme le public
peut plus apprendre à nous connaître en
regardant le spectacle et on est si
homme ensemble on essaie de briser aussi
un peu la virilité derrière ça donc si
beaucoup de sensibilité comme à chaque
représentation la machine de cirque fait
un clin d'oeil à la région dans laquelle
elle se produit reste à savoir ce qui
attend le public réunionnais ce weekend
il reste en tout cas encore quelques
places